when I developed that gnosis it was
actually through mystical medicine
experiences I got blown open my my
emergence into enlightenment
was not at all what I was expecting
well good I'm glad you're telling the
story because the next question I was
going to ask was did you have some kind
of initiation yes
please tell
if you're willing yeah
so a part of what I feel my purpose is
here is to really help awaken the world
into God Consciousness or Oneness and
what I was specifically shown
literally through every part of my
energy field very much so the physical
body
Source if if Source gave you all of
sources information in your physical
body you'd blow up there's no you can't
you can't store that much information in
Your Capacity yep
I was given as much as that as would not
kill me
yep and and nothing less
so because of that
I hear like nothing less I about
short-circuited yeah I short circuited I
literally short circuit my meridians and
so after that I was like
in this weird wonky land which um I
understand now is actually initiations
um after Enlightenment because a lot of
times people think Enlightenment is this
like end deal and it's not as a matter
of fact Enlightenment can even be looked
at as a springboard it's like okay
you understand we're all one there's you
know like it's to for people who are
truly enlightened put it this way it's
not that big of a deal
it's kind of like
it's the standard it's like can you
define Enlightenment then yeah
Enlightenment is to understand that you
are the other person and the other
person is you your different expressions
of source
so you are the all but you are also an
ambassador of the Earl of the all so I'm
you know we were talking about names
earlier I'm Sarah yeah no after
Enlightenment I had to go
I'm Sarah how funny
you're like this this fractal of source
is called Sarah yeah
I was like oh you know like I'm a human
I'm playing human right now right
so yeah there was a deep integration I'm
talking years and it could have it could
have integrated better it could have
integrated stronger had there been like
more just Baseline nutrition support
like physical things going on but yeah
that's one of the things I I tell a lot
to my clients or I when I'm at my events
and I speak to people about when they
have questions a lot of the times I try
to bring them back into like hey how are
you caring for the physical body because
it's going through a lot right now
um it's not just a metaphysical
Awakening that's happening like the body
needs to be supported through this or
else it can't even house that much
information in a congruent and clear way
I'm I'm curious and you can feel free to
answer whatever is comfortable for you
but you know I talk about it fairly
regularly on the show about and I ask a
lot of questions about plant medicine
and I feel like that's I think that's
what you alluded to so I I'm curious
what it was
um if you're if you're sure if you're
willing to share but I've found that you
know
there's gateways to other realities in a
sober sense and you can do that through
I mean shoot I had a transcendental
experience with a dog on the beach in
Mexico but
um you could do that through meditation
and various different things or you can
kind of like
kind of more guarantee the door with
some plant medicines or at least like
make it highly probable I still think
that you when your guard is up and
you're and you're not able to surrender
it still makes those those portals and
those gateways to other realities still
very difficult to access
um but I've found so much
what feels like very occult information
within them
um and truly my deepest question is in
life is what is this reality because
when I know understand what this reality
is I know how to play the game tell me
more if you're willing like what kind of
ceremony was it and you know there's
also so much so much around ceremony
right now or about plant medicines with
so Simon and Ayahuasca and peyote and
various different
um various different medicines that I
think people need to know the the the
the gravity of them and
um you know if that was something that
interested in them it's good to know the
right way to go about it too
yeah so one thing that made me a perfect
match to the ceremony being a way for
source to kind of like touch me if you
will was the fact that I have a very
broad bandwidth meaning that
for instance just
one example is an esotericism Lucifer
for instance isn't such a bad guy he's
like a frenzied Force
he comes with divine revelation he's
revered hmm there's also a downside
obviously but that's like more carnalism
more Hedonism the way that this
character is portrayed in the
exoterogram in the mainstream is
completely off base it's linked with the
devil or Satan and all these things no
lucifarian energy is one that needs to
be harnessed you have to make sure that
you can harness it but it's one that
definitely is so revered in esotericism
because it's all about gnosis
so that one example of the fact that
I have very little fear around Concepts
where most people have a lot of blocks
and fears
is just one small example I could go on
and on but really of the fact that
the more we're able to understand
complexity
and the more we're able to hold nuance
and really like Worlds at the same time
we're able to be for lack of a better
term more useful when we're in ceremony
or when we're communing or whatever
because if we're looking for a true
Awakening we're
gonna have to embody that right and that
embodiment there's a huge gap between
the mental Awakening and the embodiment
Awakening
totally totally and so because of that
the embodiment Awakening Journey looks
like completely different than the
mental Awakening Journey so to answer
your question I was in ceremony at that
time with psilocybin
I had done that several times before and
the only thing I could think of that
made that time particularly
um ripe is the fact that I was with two
very high vibrating friends so I kind of
look at them as like antennas that I
didn't know I was getting myself into
yeah it broke me it was not even like it
was nothing that it was nothing wild
there was no dose that like I was super
like oh man you're doing a hero sing it
was just to me very standard I went in
with the intention to meet my ancestors
something that was pretty grounded for
me at the time I'm in my ancestors all
right so I lost my mind in this tent to
the point where I had PTSD
for months later where I'd wake up in
the middle of the night and think I'm
still in the tent so it became like the
tent for me
but it broke my mind and I all of a
sudden was processing all this
information about source
I wrote poetry about it
I could not ground worth anything and I
kept talking to the people who were in
the tent with me as though they were on
the same level of Consciousness with me
so we were a group Consciousness and I
kept looking at them and we were all
well I found out later they didn't know
that any of this was going on they just
saw that I you know I left were you
actually talking to him or were was your
perception that you were I was talking
to them okay but everything that I said
they took it from their level of reality
but I thought that they were at my level
of reality and they weren't
so I was processing source and Source
was showing me look this is not only who
you are this is what's going on and I
started getting a bunch of information
about what's going on and I'm like and
then I got a bunch of shame because of
all the wars taking place on Earth and I
was like oh my God because I'm God I was
like I'm so much drama oh I'm so much
and I got like complete shame for all of
the conflict that I started and then it
was telling me that like you have to
come here and do what you're gonna do
like you you have to come speak and
teach and I told the other two which I
thought we were all on the same page and
I told them why do I have to be the one
to take form and I was so mad and bitter
and I want I didn't want to be the one
to be informed I I wanted to be I guess
at the time one of them that relay
information to the one who takes form so
I felt like I got the short stick like
we all Drew and I was like and they
didn't know they were like what do you
need to go to the bathroom but for me I
was like reconciling something at a
higher plane of Consciousness so I was
turning to them and I was like I don't
want to be the one to take form and I
just felt like the whole Consciousness
funneled in and said Sarah will be your
name like does that make sense what did
reality seem like in that space
what was reality as you learned it yeah
I'd never I had never seen it that way
before it was all etheric it was all
like if I was looking at you right now
you would look like
almost translucent
everything looked completely translucent
and even
Source came in in a very like
cliche typical bible-ish way very
translucent light from yeah have you
ever seen the movie I believe it's
called The Nines with Ryan Reynolds
no okay so after I had that experience
later on I saw that I'm gonna watch it
now but yeah so you have to and then I
tripped out even more because that movie
was about I don't know if I should spoil
it for you but essentially it was very
similar to my experience and I was
already trying to integrate my
experience so once I saw that that to me
was like no you cannot when you
integrate it that does not mean you
cannot pretend that this wasn't real so
once I saw that movie I was like oh no
this is my new level of reality I have
to play at this level of reality so my
Enlightenment and I say that with no ego
because like I said Enlightenment to me
is not a big deal and I know that
there's a lot of
um
taboo around that word and I think that
that taboo is there for a good reason I
can see that's the problem now I could
see everyone's perception I can see why
people have you know um boundaries up
against that word
and I think that those boundaries for
the most part the overwhelming majority
of the reason why we have an aversion to
Enlightenment is because of you know
really toxic teachings that have been
passed down throughout the ages that
with you know like the typical Guru type
however Enlightenment is you know if
there were another name I'd just use
that name because to me I don't care
about the name so I'm using the name
Enlightenment because we can all kind of
like agree that when I'm saying that
that it's talking about a specific level
of reality
and so for me it just was years process
of integrating that new level of reality
and now it's just you know I'm more
grounded if you like this clip and you
want to hear the whole episode click at
the bottom of your screen